good morning John it is likely my last
video of 2015.
2020 to 2022. Juicy crust pins get down
it's gonna be 2023 John I'm very
grateful to you for sharing some
thoughts about my books I remember when
the second one was coming out I was like
talking to Media about it and stuff and
people were like what's this about and
I'm terrible at that so I said like the
first book I kind of wrote to try and
like share more clearly what the
internet is actually like and this book
though the second one is more like what
I think it's gonna be like and it is
legitimately weird to watch as various
parallels hit I just think that fiction
writing and reading is a really good
place to find Insight because when I
think about like Elon and Twitter it's
very hard not to get caught up in a lot
of the details and a lot of like my
biggest concerns about Society what I'm
thinking about Peter and Altus it's like
oh yeah yeah I get that I know all about
that it's very easy to manufacture
whatever reasoning you need to do the
thing and get the thing that you are
hungry for and there's not that many
things that people get hungry for it's
like food is one of them water air
Joy sex meaning love it's a pretty short
list so it makes perfect sense for there
to be a character who will do literally
the opposite of what he has spent his
whole public life championing in order
to get status because it brings him
meaning and he desperately wants that we
are very bad like research shows this we
are very bad at arguing with ourselves
we almost always end up believing what
we want to believe and that's a super
fun thing to say about other people but
it's less comfortable to say about
ourselves but it is true of all of us
and it's a good thing to look at as we
head into a new year with things
changing very fast one thing I've
learned about me is that I'm very good
at becoming whatever an internet
platform wants me to be I just had a two
go viral on Mastodon I had the top two
to the day on Mastodon I got good at
YouTube and then Twitter and then Tick
Tock and I like spending time in those
places they bring me joy they bring me
connection they bring me meaning they
bring me attention so it's so hard to
trust my instincts about whether it's
good to spend time I'm in those places
and what to do while I'm there because
I'm arguing with myself and myself wants
to do it so I don't know like should I
do what we did for like the first 10
years of this and just like Vibe with
what I think is interesting and fly
toward the light like a mom or should I
be constantly second guessing myself and
wondering whether my like pro-social
biology is being hacked by algorithms
for anti-social aims that are resulting
in epidemics of misinformation and
disconnection and loneliness I guess
John I need to do both which is annoying
because it's work it's not just like job
work either it's like personal work it's
work I have to do on myself to
understand my motivations gotta
understand my responsibilities that's a
no I don't want to I don't want to do
that it sucks a little bit to feel
conflicted about the things that bring
you Joy and how do we make progress
unless we talk about problems right like
there isn't a way but I do honestly
think that there is Damage Done by never
being able to see anything without also
simultaneously critique like there is
critique there there's space for it but
you can also love it all of the people I
love there is they have space for
critique including myself everything has
room for improvement but nobody thinks
that like room for improvement is
synonymous with evil all right what I
think I'm trying to get at is that I
need to use the internet and internet
Platforms in ways where I think I'm more
engaging with problems than creating
problems more focused on doing work than
on deepening conflict but I need to err
on the side of being really quite sure
if it feels like it might be a little
bit good might be a little bit bad I'm
arguing with myself and myself as the
person who's about to get a lot of
attention and notoriety and Status by
Tweeting or saying the thing that I'm
not sure if it's good or bad are you
are you not sure or do you just not want
to look too hard at it
yeah I thought so John I will see you in
2023